foreign
[Music]
views move to Berlin and work with me I
can make you a star I'm moving to
Germany baby
I wonder who star is here nice to meet
you bumper Eddie is amazing should be
your assistant too
foreign yep
you are going to perform at German uni
today it's like the Fourth of July meets
a Super Bowl halftime show except that
we are way cooler about showing nipples
here
Ellen is going to try to play at Unity
deck it doesn't have the rage I can go
from YouTube
I just think that
yeah you know so I'm amazing the proper
performance is hard even for the most
seasoned performers somewhere I work
better under pressure what's up Berlin
letters
nope I'm out of here nope nope
[Music]
I wanted to be famous my entire life I
thought Berlin was gonna change
everything
it still could they don't know my name
if you don't take a risk you don't cry
somebody gets a match because vampa's
song is a bang what if we turn this into
a river
because you are obsessed with your whip
off riff-off whiff off Riff Off you said
with of acid with off okay
[Music]
thank God
[Music]
I'm not like a corny acapella guy I'm
cool right
right
[Music]